bonsoir les grévistes d'air france ont
réoccupé les pistes d'orly et de roissy
les crs qui sont opposés les uns et les
autres se sont affrontés des passagers
au grenier des avions sont restés
bloqués d'autres ont décollé une
négociation a commencé
le ministre des transports a fait des
propositions air france a présenté ses
excuses à ses clients
dans une lettre publiée par le monde 22
patrons français ont lancé un appel
contre cette grève dans une page publiée
par libé et le figaro et le gouvernement
ce soir est préoccupé direction henri
tout d'abord avec maryse burgot and
ponsinet épaté hp care il s'était
préparée au pire
équipements anti crs de rigueur en cette
cinquième journée de grève à orly
9h30 assemblée générale dans une
ambiance plutôt bon enfant mais toujours
la même détermination
10h30 direction les pistes de l'aérogare
d'orly sud
3000 grévistes en rangs serrés parmi eux
louis viannet ce faux père général de la
cgt mais en face le comité d'accueil est
prêt devant l'imposant cordon de crs
la tension monte
gaz lacrymogènes jets de pierres les
échauffourées ont duré trois quarts
d'heure
quelques portes défoncées quelques
vitrines brisées quelques blessés légers
mais en fait pas d'affrontement dur avec
les crs 11 heures les crs reçoivent
l'ordre de charger en quelques minutes
les 3000 manifestants ont quitté la
piste
on va les amuser autrement toute façon
sera là tous les jours tous les jours
nathalie tomi balladur ne devront pas en
ce cas là tous les jours
pauthe d'envahir les pistes ils iront
donc occuper la nationale 7
une belle pagaille qui va durer plus
d'une heure les usagers bloqués prennent
leur mal en patience et vont à pied
15h30 nouvelle assemblée générale au
même endroit que ce matin les il ya du
nouveau
le ministre des transports demande
l'ouverture de négociations
quand on lit leur télex ya rien de neuf
pour nous et nous dit plomb et est
incontournable c'est parce qu'on veut
nous ce soir le calme est revenu sur
l'aéroport d'orly nouvelle assemblée
générale demain matin